Josh Norman do people in the NFL think
you're weird smell what is going on yeah
left go here in Virginia to get a tour
of Josh Norman sin sane house 5,400
square feet of toys bells and whistles
and with all that he better have good
homeowners insurance and I really hope
it's with State Farm State Farm is
sponsoring this episode but they also
have phenomenal homeowners insurance I
wouldn't steer you wrong let's go ditch
the playbook just in case you didn't
know whose house it was yeah he let you
know right in the driveway Jay no 24
Josh Norman well the best quarterbacks
in the league I gotta see what makes him
the most interesting man in the NFL well
good to see you you look good good see
your house is amazed come on man come on
in
I like the art I like the tone like the
colors so this is the volleyball court
that I've heard about this is movie
theater level amounts of candy Wow
I could feel it in my bones red
everybody has a pair of shoes that kind
of represents them the books to the wall
which ones which one is Josh Norman
which one is me that represents me the
most out of the shoes this is it that's
why as I have seen I was gonna say it's
by itself is by itself no matter what
city Josh live no matter where he goes
in the world he is still a cowboy boot
wearing horse rear in country man hey
it's through you blood all the way
through your blood this is my very own
personal barber shop oh you got your
logo on so do you have like your own
private masseuse yes I have my own pet
masseuse come go right through them
actually me masseuses so you get your
hair cut in the basement you get your
massages upstairs you really do not need
to leave this house you see one-stop
shop there's not a lot of NFL players
that do Dancing with the Stars
there's not a lot of NFL players that
have giraffes in their living room yeah
man I mean do people then I felt think
you're weird yeah he's a little bit off
a little bit off I'll show you the best
room in the house really out of all the
rooms this is the best one okay
Oh fine this is the perfect spot for
your kid this is the lair
[Music]
I love the fact that there is a pony at
a table with what looks to be for the
most incredible makeup jobs I've ever
seen
you know and I've never seen anything
better never what is that
come on
what is going on I'm a little barbarian
this is like 50 60 pounds yes bro you're
such a nerd I love this do that
big-time yeah please tell me that you
wear that around the house this should
be the new helmet the NFL can you
imagine if somebody try to break it in
Josh Norman's house and he came upstairs
with a sward and it's serious I know
you're obsessed with Batman like with
every morsel of your body so when I came
in and I saw this man like yeah but the
arse we did it suck what do you mean
that look like me what we're supposed to
look like you
yes supposed to oh this was supposed to
be you and a bat oh that sound good
exactly sure let me show you this bar
take a wild guess what you think this is
I got wood chips this is mama one imma
want to know what that is
oh really this is why he's the most
interesting man about every house
there's always that thing where they go
and this is where the magic happens
I'm not gonna do it how does it feel it
feels like a very soft plush bed you
know no chinchilla you turn it up
the better shaking Josh what do you what
is this like a massage type of thing I
don't feel comforted this is where the
magic oh this is the z/28 72
split-bumper Chevrolet Camaro smell
nothing my own school
[Music]
this is Batman's Batmobile right here
hope you guys enjoyed meet the most
interesting man the NFL well while we're
ditching the playbook I got a ditch you
guys man it's all holler at you let's do
it what's up the artist Muhammad snow
with New England Patriots make sure you
subscribe the bleacher report YouTube
for more videos like this